un bon enseignant qu'est ce que c'est un
bon prof c'est surtout un prof qui
arrive à nous de nous expliquer un prof
créatures coin tranquille qui s'est
inventé des choses n'est qu'en disait
des élèves en 1973 à mon professeur
c'est un professeur qui s'est intéressé
en un mot du primaire à la terminale
c'est une histoire de pédagogie mais il
a fallu du temps pour intégrer cette
notion dans la formation des enseignants
très exactement l'année 1974
sur proposition du ministre de
l'éducation il y aura une part
importante très important à signaler
les enseignants vont être des pédagogues
mais c'est considérable c'est une c'est
une révolution missionné les étudiants
bénéficient de quelques jours de stage
en situation en classe seulement
quelques jours ce n'est pas assez pour
bien transmettre à l'enfant parole
d'enseignants la relation à la classe la
connaissance de l'enfant sur le plan
psychologique
l'animation de groupes par exemple qui
sont des éléments qui font partie de
notre métier ne sont jamais abordées à
aucun moment de pont du cursus
universitaire la révolution elle arrive
en 1990 en quatre lettres iufm les
instituts universitaires de formation
des maîtres à savoir ces trois choses à
lui à femmes c'est ce que l'enseignant
de savoir ce que les enfants ont besoin
de savoir et la troisième chose c'est
comment on transmet aux enfants en
seconde année de master les étudiants
suivent des stages de pédagogie la
pression on m'explique des choses au
clair les iufm ont disparu en 2011 après
une réforme remplacés en 2013 par les
aspects écoles supérieures du
professorat et de l'éducation là
nouveauté un mi temps en classe en 2ème
année avec un professeur tuteur la
pédagogie en quelques décennies a bien
évolué exercice 1 jour quand même plus
ludique que les méthodes d'antan
[Musique]